what I like especially about the first
part of this when you came on about the
open sourceness
I am I'm not an academic but I'm trained
as an academic so I like open source and
then the question about the briefing so
why won't you release it well there's
names okay that's cool and then you have
released it to some of the people who
are at some live event now is there a
reason that it's exclusive to people at
a live event because I'm sure then oh no
it's up on our YouTube channel now
remember our YouTube channel has like
500 videos some of which are two to four
hours long and it's Dr Stephen Greer
it's whatever it is it's like in PDF
form I mean like PowerPoint presentation
or however it is that you deliver yes
well that's those are going to be create
that's what we're creating so this huge
archive that we're collecting that we're
putting together for the US government
White House National Security Council
Congress that we're going to have a
version of it when we get it done
hopefully in the next uh 10 months that
would be accessible by the public
but you know again you have to
understand we're not a Rich Podcast like
you we're of all volunteers and uh we
don't have an office or staff now I am
hiring away from an aerospace company
I'm not a Rich Podcast just so you know
oh I saw same oh well you know when I
was on Joe Rogan you know those kind of
people I was never offered 2 billion oh
you weren't given 100 million dollars by
Spotify and you know if you would take
my interview out of the lineup you know
that's what Joe Rogan did he took he
took my interview out of the lineup so
we could get the 100 million dollars
from my Spotify oh yeah how do you think
deals like that are made there's a quid
pro quo let's take out anything that's
really inflammatory anyway
um you see how cynical I am about the
media uh big media so in any rate well
okay firstly like I recommend you I'm
happy that you're on and I appreciate
that you're willing to come in here and
answer some questions that again like it
sounds answering but just a fatuous
person so when I say what's evidence for
so-and-so I mean no disrespect it's just
my um we have all the evidence you want
but again we put these together in so
many formats where there's video books
but most people you know they can only
stand reading the headlines so if people
want to drill down in It Go drill down
on them I have five books out
um there are you know like I said a
thousand hours or more of of really
densely packed information and
presentations with those PowerPoints on
the YouTube channel great great I
appreciate that you're not offended by
it I I appreciate that at all I mean
there'll be more questions like that
coming yeah there'll be anyone like that
should uh you know I mean but what I say
is say you know go do it you know I
can't spoon feed it to you if you're not
not willing to read of course nobody
it's Politically Incorrect to read or do
math as you know